nous sommes toujours à l'université de
Berre de l'Ouest parisien avec Valérie
pcrest bonjour madame la Présidente de
la Région île-de-fance bonjour euh c'est
d'ailleurs c'est un passage naturel pour
vous devenir vous êtes élu des ivelines
vous êtes une ivelinoise absolument
toujours conseillère municipal de véisie
vill coublais et élu de la communauté de
commune de Versailles Grand Parc
alors les Yvelines aujourd'hui vont
connaître une immense transformation
c'est l'arrivée des Hol oui et donc on
est en train de préparer cette cette
immense transformation avec tous les M
parce que la région c'est un orchestre
de M et l'arrivée d'un transport comme
celui-là dans la vallée de Scine c'est
despôlesgardes dans chaque commune c'est
donc un bouleversement de chaque ville
qui permet de repenser tous les
circulations le l'écologie le logement
l'emploi dans chaque ville c'est vrai
que alors là pour l'instant ça va être
saint-lazar àchel ça va être ça va aller
jusqu'à man EOL il y a aussi la ligne 15
puisqu'on parle aussi des Hut SC et
puisque c'est l'ouest parisien et c'est
vrai que tous ces travaux tous ces
changements au fond ça change la la
l'identité même d'une région non ah ben
le Grand Paris Express c'est 330 km de
métro je pense que les franens ne se
rendent même plus compte de ce que ça va
faire vous habiterez dans les Yvelines
vous pourrez aller jusqu'à horly
aéroport en métro ça soit de Versailles
jusqu'à horly direct soit en allant à
Paris et en prenant le le métro vers
Orly donc la vérité c'est que on va
complètement changer les modes de vie
des Franciliens on pourra aller à roiss
aussi avec des métros qui partiront de
de la gare saint-lazar vers saint-n puis
en ensuite vers vers rissi donc on va
complètement bouleverser les modes de
vie les modes de transport trans
l'installation des entreprises qui vont
s'installer évidemment beaucoup plus en
vallée de SC on va permettre la
réindustrialisation de cette vallée on
va permettre la désaturation des du RERB
qui est un énorme sujet pour tout le sud
parce que avec la ligne 15 avec la ligne
18 avec la ligne 14 ben on aura des
itinéraire alternatif en métro
automatique donc vraiment il va y avoir
un effet waou qui va commencer dès
l'année prochaine et qui va se prolonger
jusqu'en 2031 c'est ça 2025 c'est EOL
c'est ça 2024 c'estol à la défense 2026
EOL à Mont la jolieie ensuite on aura en
2024 Saint- playel Orly en 2025 on aura
la ligne 15 la ligne 15 la ligne 15 pont
de Sèvre noisichamp premier tronçon donc
et ensuite en 26 en 27 vous aurez Massis
àé puis ensuite
hor versaill donc oui donc d'ici 2030 le
paysage va totalement être boulversé
d'ailleurs ce que disent les géographes
le le le le la vraie géographie c'est
pas c'est pas la distance c'est le temps
absolument c'est le temps et quand vous
imaginez que vous allez pouvoir faire
MTE la jolie la défense en étant assis
sans embouteillage en transport
tranquille en en 50 minutes évidemment
ça change tout alors puisque vous parlez
de d'OL et et de de grand Paris Express
euh on va parler quand même de cet
accord que vous avez passé avec Clément
B le ministre des Transports sur les
transports d'î de France euh ça faisait
longtemps hein que vous disiez il faut
trouver des financements l'accord a étit
passé je crois que c'était le 26
septembre vous avez parlé d'un accord
historique
oui absolument ça fait 10 ans qu'on sait
que c'est 330 km de nouvelle ligne c'est
70 nouvelles gares qu'on va ouvrir et
bien ça va coûter de l'argent et donc il
faut trouver le moyen de financer alors
certains
Bruno Le Maire et d'autres disaent on a
qu'à faire payer les usagers moi j'ai
dit le Pass Navigo à 120 € c'est pas mon
modèle Londres ça n'est pas mon modèle
nous on garde l'idée d'un modèle à la
française où les usagers payent leur
part et donc le Pass Navigo
malheureusement devra augmenter mais il
paye raisonable il ne sera pas gelé
parce que ce serait pas raisonable avec
tout ce qu'on va ouvrir il faut aussi
que les usagers payent leur écho donc on
fera un bouclier ire pour les usagers on
nugmentera jamais leur cotisation à plus
d'inflation plus 1 % c'est l'accord que
j'ai avec les départements et les
départements et la région eu payeront
inflation plus 2 % ça veut dire que les
départements les départements viennent
d'accepter l'accord que je leur ai
proposé on signe demain et je voudrais
vraiment les remercier pour la région ça
va représenter quand même 470 millions
d'euros supplémentaire que je mets sur
la table pour les départements et la
ville de Paris de leur côté aussi et
l'idée c'est c'est qu'on montte
l'exemple qu'on dise qu'on va aussi
financer mais on doit faire payer aussi
les touristes on doit faire payer aussi
les entreprises de plus de 11 salariés
en petite couronne parce que les
entreprises de petite cour protestent
les entreprises he d'ailleurs oui elles
protestent mais il faut être raisonnable
le versement mobilité c'est pas un impôt
comme les autres le versement mobilité
les entreprises c'est une somme qui nous
donne pour faire circuler les transport
et quand on multiplie par de le réseau
de métro bah forcément le versement
mobilité il doit aussi connaître une
hausse ça n'est pas possible autrement
sinon ça voudrait dire que on fait les
transports gratuits pour au profit des
entreprises parce que quand on ouvre une
ligne à la défense une ligne à or
aéroport une ligne à roissie direct mais
c'est pour les entreprises donc elles
vont en
bénéf elles pourront s'installer aussi
dans dans C absolumement mais attendez
vous imaginez on leur fait quand même 36
milliards d'euros de nouveaux transports
qui vont les aider à à transporter leurs
salariés qui vont les aider à valoriser
leur siège social quand elles sont dans
des endroits qui n'ont pas de transport
donc ob effectivement c'est aussi un
formidable cadeau qu'on fait aux
entreprises alors il y a un autre
dossier qui va tir à cœur c'est celui de
la transition écologique et et puisque
nous sommes à l'université desber
justement comment la région aide bah la
communes à rénover les places publiques
les écoles c'est très important on avit
un débat là-dessus sur les dépenses
énergétiques des écoles qui sont
évidemment très très fortes aujourd'hui
euh comment qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans ce qu'on appelle les
contrats d'aménagement régionaux alors
la région c'est un orchestre de mer
toute la stratégie régionale de
transition écologique d'éducation de
lutte contre les inégalités
territoriales toute cette stratégie là
de de politique du logement toute cette
stratégie elle ne peut marcher que si
les MRES font oui bien sûr donc on donne
des des des des lignes directrices on
dit il faut construire d'avantage du
logement abordable il faut construire
aussi de l'accession à la propriété mais
tout ça ça ne marchera que si les mères
font donc comment est-ce qu'on peut les
inciter à faire par des subventions donc
la région est très très alante sur les
subventions communes on vous l'avez dit
on a un outil qui s'appelle le contrat
d'aménagement régional et pour les
toutes petites communes de moins de 2000
habitants on a le contrat rural et
l'idée c'est qu'avec ces centaines de
contrats que nous signons chaque année
nous aidons les villes à concrétiser
leurs projets d'investissement les
écoolle la transition
écologique les services publics de
proximité la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux la sécurité sur tous ces sujet
là la région de la nature aussi dans les
villes la région est immensément
présente et nous avons créé une agence
s'appelle î defance nature ou dont
l'objectif est uniquement d'aider les
villes à revégétaliser et donc on a
identifié 138 communes en île-de-fance
qui sont carencés en espace vert qui
sont nos priorités et on veut les aider
à désimperméabiliser leur sol et puis on
parle de mobilité douce mais nous allons
travailler avec le département des
Yvelines et le département des Hautes
scèes à des plans véloé c'est ce qu'on
appelle le vélo ilî-de-france c'est un
réseau de 450 km 11 nouvelles lignes de
vélo qui permettront de faire du vélotaf
le vélotaf c'est aller travailler à vé
ou PIR ou au TA aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
il y a 800000 vélotaffeurs et on
voudrait passer à 2400000 vélo taffeur
en Île-de-France x 3 alors évidemment
pas quand il neige pas quand il pleut
mais quand il fait beau euh il y a aussi
un autre dossier qui est intéressant qui
concerne plus les hautes scèes mais
c'est le réaménagement des berges de la
scène notamment à jeun Villier enfin là
aussi il y a un gros effort de la région
hein sur ce sur absolument on est en
partenariat très étroit à la fois avec
àopas mais aussi avec les les hautes
scines avec les ivelines sur toute la
réappropriation des berges de la scène
euh vous savez que l'Île-deFrance
s'appelle l'île-de-fance parce qu'au
moyen-âge quand il y avait des
inondations on aurait dit des îles des
Petites îles parce que depuis on a
drainé les marécage depuis on a asséché
on a asséché les les les les points
d'eau mais encore aujourd'hui voilà la
scène c'est quelque chose que nous avons
en partage et elle a été très
industrialisée et aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on la redécouvreû vous avez créé
aussi à Flin un campus des métiers de la
transition écologique alors c'est vrai
que parfois on est un peu haqué parce
qu'on dit il y a beaucoup de métiers qui
disparaissent et puis mais il y a
beaucoup d'autres métiers qui vont
apparaître et ça en fait partie oui
alors le le Grand Paris sur fin moi on
m'a arraché la moitié du cœur quand on a
dit qu'on ferait qu'on fabriquerait plus
d'automobile à Flin d'ailleurs la région
entre parenèse va réorienter toutes ses
aides à l'achat des véhicules
électriques en les on va les augmenter
de 50 on pourra avoir jusqu'à 9000 €
d'aide pour acheter une voiture
électrique en île-de-fance ah oui une a
spécifique d'île France on a des aides
spécifiques île- de France 9000 jusqu'à
9000 € exist pour le vélo voilà elles
existaient pour les vélo elles
existaient pour les voitures mais
seulement jusqu'à 6000 € et on pouvait
acheter n'importe quelle voiture moi
désormais on pourra acheter que des
voitures fabriquées dans des pays bac
carbon parce que la France est un pays
bac carbone et moi j'en ai assez de
payer des voitures chinoises ou même
américaines ou même allemandes je suis
désolé c'est des pays qu' sont pas bac
carbone c'est dans les pays bac carbon
qu'on doit construire les voitures et
donc voilà je le dis pour qu'on
peut-êtreon aura un jour à nouveau des
voitures qui seront fabriquées chez
Renault en Île-de-France alors cela dit
sur Flin on a fait un Paris c'est le
Paris de de faire une nouvelle usine
d'un autre type la r Factory une usine
qui fera du rétrofit de véhiculle
c'estàdire qui transformera les véhicul
circulaire quoi en gros absolument qui
transformera les véhicul thermique en
changeant le moteur en véhicule
électrique alors est-ce que ça va
marcher bah on sait pas si le rérofit va
marcher mais en tout cas c'est un Paris
industriel qu'on fait et on se dit que
peut-être les véhicules ben demain ils
vivront 1 million de kilomètr parce
qu'on changera le moteur à mi-parcours
et on le remplacera en moteur électrique
et ça c'est c'est essentiel pour la
transition écologique justement c'est
essentiel pour la transition écologique
et pour le pouvoir d'achat parce que ça
veut dire qu'on est'est pas obligé de
racheter une voiture on rachète que le
moteur un dossier qui est assez
important sur lequel vous êtes intervenu
c'est le la rénovation de la tour
Neptune à manth alors c'est vrai que là
il y avait des habitants plutôt modestes
hein et et au fond est-ce que comme ça
quand on rénove des des tours comme
celle-là ça rend les habitants fiers de
de de l'endroit où ils habitent alors la
lutte contre les copropriétés dégradées
c'est un gros enjeu parce que vous savez
qu'il y a la rénovation urbaine et que
la rénovation urbaine fait beaucoup pour
les les quartiers HLM les quartiers
populaires mais au-delà de la rénovation
des HLM on a besoin aussi de s'attaquer
à ces copropriétés dégradées et très
souvent dans ces propriété dégradé euh
bah souvent les tours au départ elles
étaient belles parce que ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que quand on les a
construites au départ ces tours de mant
la jolie c'était un quartier à la mode
il y avait des grands investisseurs à
l'époque je crois même que Louis Vuitton
avait acheté une tour enfin il y a des
grands investisseurs qui s'étaient qui
sét qui s installé dans ces tours et
donc on les a laissé se dégrader parce
que dans ses copropriétés se sont
installés des marchands de sommeil
c'est-à-dire des propriétaires
indélicats qui ont mis des euh des
demi-douzaines de de locataires dans
entassés dans l'appartement qui ont
arrêté de payer leur charge de
copropriété et du coup la tour est
tombée et donc là dans la tour nepturne
mais il y avait une copropriété hyper
dynamique qui a repris en main la tour
qui a expulsé les les les marchands de
sommeil et nous nous les avons aidé
parce queon est venu au secours de cette
tour et on le fait ici on le fait aussi
à greininy 2 on le fait aussi aux
chaînes pointu à Montfermeil c'est
coproprité dégradé il faut aider les
propriétaires à s'en sortir et
àé les lieux un mot alors peut-être plus
général c'est vrai que vous plaidez
depuis un certain nbre d'années pour un
choc de décentralisation qui visiblement
ne vient
pas il y a vous avez un collègue qui est
le président de la Région nouvelle
aququitaine qui est Plô socialiste enfin
qui a dit Emmanuel Macron n'aime pas les
régions est-ce que mais alors je sais
pas si je pas vous demander de confirmer
ou d'infirmer ça mais c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y a une incompr entre
le pouvoir central le pouvoir d'État et
puis les élus régionaux les élus locaux
et puis qu'on l'Université des m c'est
important ça fait mal à l'état de
l'entendre mais nous on est tenu par
l'équilibre budgétaire on n pas le droit
de s'endetter pour faire du fonction
vous reprochz de de dépenser beaucoup
aux région B non on peut pas on n pas le
droit on n pas le droit de faire des
chèqus sans provision Paron a pas le
droit de faire des déficits de
fonctionnement donc forcément on est
bien géré et et donc on réclame d'avoir
plus de compétences puisqu'on les gère
bien puisquon les gère à l'EUR l'urou et
et je pense qu'on serait on est quand
même beaucoup plus en prise avec les
réalités du terrain je vous donne un
seul exemple mais le plan France
industrie quand il est fait au ministère
de des finances la région -defrance
c'est un seul bassin d'emploi est-ce que
c'est raisonnable est-ce que un emploi
vaut la même prix est-ce que un emploi
vaut le même prix à la défense ou
justement à Mt la jolie ou à Chantelou
lesvges mais non bien sûr que non moi
j'ai intérêt aujourd'hui à pouvoir
positionner les emplois dans les
quartiers populaires qui se sont
désindustrialisés dans lesquels j'ai des
fortes chage donc moi quand je regarde
la région je regarde pas un seul bassin
d'emploi je regarde je dis pas
j'investis en île-de-fance je dis
j'investis à tel endroit donc la maille
de la région est beaucoup plus précise
et puis par ailleurs je peux apporter
des services c'est-à-dire que lorsque je
crée un emploi je peux apporter les
transports je peux apporter du logement
donc ça fait du sens celui qui gère les
bassins d'emploi c'est l'Île-de-France
c'est pour ça qu'on demande vraiment la
compétence emploi moi je vois l'autre
jour je regardais la banque de données
de Pôle emploi je me suis aperçu qu'il y
avait des dizaines de mil de salariés
qui étai inscrit à pôemploi dans les
métiers de la sécurité dans les métiers
du tourisme mais alors y a des centaines
de milliers d'offrees ouvertes donc il y
a des
dysfonctionn y a des dysfonctionnements
comme dirait amelette il y a quelque
chose de pourri au royaume du Danemark
mais on n pas au Danemark non alors Val
les étudiants de Sciences vous ont
écouté et vous poser des questions on va
commencer par NAD bonjour NAD
étudi
bonjour euh madame la Présidente moi ma
question elle va aborder une autre
thématique l'attractivité plus
précisément comment l'attractivité du
territoire de l'Île-de-France l'Est
parisien que vous connaissez bien il est
pensé au niveau national et
international donc on a l'exemple des GO
2024 mais est-ce que vous avez d'autres
actions bah la région île-de-fance elle
est partie prenante des trois plus
grands plans d'investissement du pays le
premier c'est le Grand Paris Express on
en a parlé 330 km de Mt
c'est un effet totalement waou sur tous
les transports d'île-de-fance et ça va
complètement changer l'attractivité de
l'Île-de-France quand on pourra aller à
rissi en métro direct à Orly en métro
direct à la défense et même jusqu'à mant
la jolie en méro directect ça change
tout donc ce premier plan 36 milliards
d'euros est un plan est un plan énorme
le deuxième plan c'est les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques vous l'avez
dit qui vont être regardés par 3
milliards de spectateurs donc il faut
qu'on montre ce qu'on a de plus beau à
Paris à Versailles au grand en stade et
puis qu'on montre l'île-de-fance à tous
les touristes à tous les investisseurs
qu'on les amène chez nous pour investir
et le troème plus grand plan de national
c'est le plan des lycées d'île-de-fance
alors je le dis parce que c'est la
jeunesse doit être notre priorité en
île-de-fance on est la région la plus
jeune de France après les Haut- de
France je mets de côté les outrmers mais
en métropole la région la plus jeune de
France on a une population jeune qui a
un fort taux de chômage le sujet de
l'éducation des jeunes le sujet de
l'enseignement professionnel le sujet de
l'orientation des jeunes sont des sujets
que la Région veut prendre à bras le
corps 6 milliard 5 de plans de
rénovation de lycée la gauche m'avait
laissé des lycées totalement véuses
c'est pas digne et vous savez on dit on
veut revaloriser l'enseignement
professionnel on veut emmener les jeunes
vers les métiers de l'industrie et du
numérique qui recrutent qui sont les
métiers de l'avenir mais quand vous
arrivez dans un lycée professionnel tout
pourri B vous avez pas l'impression que
c'est un métier d'avenir et vous avez
pas l'impression que la République vous
attend donc la région elle investit pour
l'avenir et investit notamment pour ses
jeunes avec la création d'une agence qui
s'appelle Orian qui est l'agence de
l'orientation pour les jeunes pour les
conduire vers ses métiers nouveaux qui
ne connaissent pas que les familles ne
connaissent pas alors il y a on
travaille sur toute la gamme les
décrocheurs on les raccroche 30000
décrocheurs en Île-de-France par an les
jeunes collégiens lycéen on les guide et
puis les jeunes sans emploi ni formation
et bien on les ramène vers des métiers
qui recrutent et vers des carrières
merci merci Mathieu c'est à
VOUS bonjour Mathie merci donc on on a
beaucoup parlé de transport j'aimerais
revenir avec vous sur une annonce
récente du gouvernement sur la mise en
œuvre du passeril donc cette cet
abonnement mensuel inspiré du modèle
allemand qui offre aux usagers un accès
illimité aux offres de train régionaux
et partout en France alors le ministre
des Transports a annoncé que ce projet
serait cofinancé par l'État et les
régions quel est votre positionnement
sur cette proposition non mais cette
annonce est totalement Pipo moi je l'ai
dit elle est totalement Pipo c'est du
pipo c'est de l'enfumage c'est
impossible en île-de-fance parce que un
pass à 49 € en île-de-fance pour tout le
monde le Pass il est aujourd'hui comme
vous le savez à 84 € pour le mettre à 49
€ il faudrait trouver 1 milliard 8
1illard800 million d'euros l'année
prochaine de recette et moi le
gouvernement m'a pas
dit m'a pas donné la moindre piste pour
trouver 1 milillard 800 million d'euros
donc c'est une annonce totalement Pipo
c'est du vent c'est de l'enfumage
c'était pour faire bien à la télé voilà
donc ça n'arrivera jamais voilà parce
que le gouvernement est absolument
incapable de mettre sur la table cet
argent et la région qui a 5 milliards de
budget aussi voilà si je peux me
permettre il est pourtant mis en place
en Occitanie est-ce que le modèle est le
même ah bah oui mais c'est normal en
Occitanie il y a personne dans les
trains attendez pardon l'occcitanie on
parle pas de la même chose alleer vivre
en Occitanie vous savez combien il y a
de personnes dans les les trains en
Île-de-France 9 millions tous les jours
9 millions en Occitanie ça doit être
allez quelques centaines de milliers de
personnes on parle pas de la même chose
les trains en Île-de-France c'est un
budget de 12 milliards par an par an de
fonctionnement 12 milliards donc comme
vous êtes à sciencep mais que vous
faites aussi de l'économie de la gestion
je vous invite à venir voir comment ça
fonctionne en île-de-fance et vous
comprendrez que c'est pas si vous savez
je suis une femme politique hein moi
aussi j'adoreraai faire tout gratuit si
je pouvais le faire je le ferais et vous
seriez heureux et vous voteriez pour moi
donc vous savez c'est pas parce que j'ai
pas envie c'est juste parce que à un
moment donné tout a un prix il y a
toujours quelqu'un qui paye à la fin et
les services publics gratuits il y a
si vous pouviez sortir de sciencep en
ayant compris ça je pense vous auriez
fait un bon en avant et que vous seriez
prêt à diriger une entreprise publique
tu as fait un
bon merci beaucoup Mathieu merci
beaucoup Vale vous et bonne
université